[Music]
a deadly air strike on a Gaza hospital
this Tuesday night casualties said to be
in the hundreds and the pleas to lift
Israel's Siege on Gaza so Aid and
medicine can get in an Israeli woman
with family in Canada is laid to rest
this is pure hate against Jews as
exhausted healthcare workers are
overwhelmed with patience and with their
own grief back in Canada inflation slows
down the lingering Financial
frustrations so this month's been pretty
tight and the relief grocery Shoppers
are getting for
now global national with Donna
F gazin were already Dying by the dozens
every day and now this Doctors Without
Borders describes it as horrifying it
appears a hospital in Gaza took a direct
hit the health Ministry says hundreds of
people have been killed the AL Aki
hospital is run by the Anglican Church a
church spokesperson says it 600 beds
were full and at least 1,000 people were
Sheltering on the grounds and this is
the second time it's been hit the head
of the Anglican Church calls it an
appalling and devastating loss of
innocent lives Israel denies it was
responsible saying the Israeli Defense
Force does not Target hospitals it
claims all indications are the blast was
caused by an Islamic Jihad rocket that
misfired inside Gaza Israel's prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu said in a
statement those who brutally murdered
our children also murder their own
children good evening and thanks for
joining us it is too early to verify who
fired the missile the US president who
is on route to Israel tonight said he is
outraged by the explosion and has
directed his National Security team to
continue gathering information about
what exactly happened int intentionally
hitting a hospital is a war crime and
that is what a number of leaders in the
Arab world are already calling it while
Russia and the UAE have requested an
emergency un security council meeting
this is what Canada's prime minister had
to say International humanitarian and
and international law needs to be
respected uh in in this and in all cases
There Are Rules around Wars and it's not
acceptable to H the the attack on a
hospital adds to the tension in the
region and to the humanitarian crisis in
Gaza Crystal ganing begins our coverage
tonight the sound of Screams and calls
for help are deafening in southern Gaza
where Palestinians were told to flee by
Israel Defense Forces the injured pour
out of ambulances and
Cars nearby in Rafa were people
including Palestinian Canadians raced to
the border with Egypt hoping to escape
air strikes rain down Hamas blamed
Israel for the deadly attack on the
hospital Israel said it would
investigate but is suggesting that it
was a misfired rocket by Islamic
jihadists what we do know for certain is
that thousands were taking shelter at
the hospital a un run school and homes
were also struck Tuesday a UN Human
Rights office spokesperson said more
than 4,000 people have been killed over
the past 10 days the death toll includes
a large number of women and children as
well as at least 11 Palestinian
journalists 28 medical staff and 14 un
colleagues Israeli officials have
repeatedly stated they are targeting
Hamas officials and militant
infrastructure in Gaza and that Israel
takes steps to protect civilian lives
including the warnings last week for
people to seek safety in southern Gaza
we're concerned that this order comp
combined with the imposition of a
complete Siege on Gaza may not be
considered as lawful temporary
evacuation and would therefore amount to
a forcible transfer of civilians in
breach of international
law water food Fuel and medical supplies
are ready to be trucked into Gaza as a
host of Aid agencies plead for Access
wfp has tons of food coming in from
Planes and trucks around the region
piled up and ready for the green light
to enter into Gaza from any possible
entry
point the attack on the Al Ali Hospital
emphasizes the fear and hopelessness of
people living in
Gaza my fear is for my children my fear
is for my relatives my fear is for my
neighbors I fear for all of Gaza
children are dying with the
deteriorating humanitarian crisis in
Gaza there appears to be no safe haven
for civilians turkey's president RAB T
erdogan saying the attack on the
hospital I want to read this quote to
you is the lady latest example of
Israel's attacks devoid of the most
basic human values Cutter's foreign
minister also issuing a statement
strongly condemning Israel for the
strike on the hospital in Gaza Donna all
right crystal ganing in Jerusalem
thanks in the West Bank hundreds of
Palestinians are out on the streets
angry about the attack on the hospital
in Gaza in rala the seat of the
Palestinian Authority protesters clashed
with security forces who use tear gas
and stun grenades to try to disperse the
crowds in the 11 days since the massacre
by Hamas of israelies in their homes and
the loss of life has been staggering
according to the health Ministry in Gaza
nearly 3,000 people have been killed
that number will rise after the hit on
that hospital in Gaza in Israel the
death toll is reported to be more than
1,400 it's believed at least 199 other
people including children have been
taken hostage by Hamas two can Canadians
are thought to be among them late last
night Hamas released the first video
appearing to show one of the hostages a
21-year-old French Israeli woman
captured at a music festival it's
unclear when the video was taken as Jeff
simple reports her mother is begging the
world to bring her baby home I didn't
know she's still alive yesterday Karen
shim's 21-year-old daughter Mia was one
of the thousands attending a music
festival near the Gaza border when Hamas
gunman attacked for 9 days her family
feared she was dead until they saw her
on TV I saw a shout I felt on the floor
and to scream her daughter appeared in
this Hamas hostage video in it Mia says
she's in Gaza and that her hand was
injured so she had an
[Music]
operation they are taking care of me she
says everything is fine I only ask that
someone return me home as soon as
possible it's not known where or when
the video was recorded or if the
comments were made under duress she
looks very
terrified she looks like she's in big
day I'm begging the world to bring my
baby back home Israeli officials say Mia
is one of around 200 Hamas hostages
captured during its Saturday morning
Massacre their faces now plastered on
this wall of the missing just across
from Israel's defense Ministry in Tel
Aviv this rally started spontaneously
One Week Ago by aii broich after his
wife and three young children were
kidnapped by Hamas the message is to
prioritize the the women and children uh
it's the message to Hamas as well before
long others joined bro's brother lives
in Toronto and came here for support
these are you know kids we love
they unbelievable the list of Presumed
hostages includes two two Canadians
another Israeli whose family is from
Canada tiferet lapido was also thought
to be among the hostages until this
week the 23-year-old's body was just
recovered from the music festival site
her funeral was delayed by 30 minutes
because the mourners couldn't be
consoled we're buring our kids this is
pure hate against Jews people say
they're animals they're not animal an
animals just kill to eat to survive they
kill because they hate labo's father is
from Saskatchewan we hope the Canadian
people will support Israel and
most most right fight against evil a
Hamas spokesperson says the foreign
hostages are their guests who will be
released when circumstances allow it's
clear from the messaging that Hamas is
trying to put forward a friendlier face
but the Unspeakable pain pain caused by
so many young lives lost is not so
easily painted over Donna right Jeff SLE
in Jerusalem thank you it was announced
yesterday the American President Joe
Biden would go to the Middle East a
diplomatic mission to show support for
Israel but also to try to deescalate
Jackson prco is with me from Washington
Jackson after that attack on the
hospital in Gaza did the president get
on the plane he did Donna but no one
knows what the situation will be like by
the time he actually lands in Israel
tomorrow the reason being that he's
already had to cut part of his trip
short he is no longer attending a summit
in Jordan with the leaders of Jordan
Egypt and the Palestinian Authority they
had backed out of meeting with Biden
after that explosion at the Gaza
hospital that said Biden is still
pressing ahead with his meeting with
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu he has very specific goals in
his meetings with the Israelis
specifically reassuring us support for
that country country and trying to
negotiate a humanitarian Corridor out of
Gaza both for foreign Nationals and to
allow some sort of Aid in Biden has also
said to want some sort of assessment of
what Israel's military goals for its
eventual ground Invasion may look like
to get a better understanding of what
they are and what support the US can
provide we should of course point out
that the US has already announced the
deployment of two aircraft carriers to
the region and there are thousands of
troops on standby but it's a precarious
security situation that the president is
walking into not only is his own
security at risk and we've seen other
visiting leaders and dignitaries have to
take shelter from incoming rocket fire
but we should point out that American
interests across the Middle East are
tonight very much at heightened security
alert and facing massive widespread
protests after what happened in Gaza
today and back here in Washington Donna
we know that government buildings
including the US capital building behind
me are also now increasing their
security posture tomorrow ahead of
expected protests with Biden in that
volatile region all right Jackson prco
in Washington as President Biden heads
to Israel thanks Jackson the United
States is dealing with an increase in
aggressive behavior from China the
Pentagon says the Chinese military has
conducted more than 180 risky intercepts
in the past two years off China's Coast
something Canada encountered yesterday
on Monday Global News is on board a
Canadian military Patrol aircraft
operating in international airspace when
Chinese Jets intercepted it off the
coast of China China says Canada
violated its sovereignty and threatened
its National Security the US calls it
part of a Brazen show of
intimidation I'm most concerned about
the potential for accidents and those
accidents could lead to
miscalculation we must prevent these
from happening in the theater in June
Global News captured a Chinese warship
coming within 137 meters of a US
Destroyer conducting a joint Mission
with Canada in the Taiwan
straight every country has Intelligence
agencies including Canada but we rarely
see them or hear from them that's why a
security Summit in California today is
extraordinary the heads of intelligence
from the so-called five eyes Canada the
US the UK Australia and New Zealand not
only met they spoke in public about the
threats we're facing our David Aken
listened
in this terrific partnership that we
have and historic event the first time
ever that the heads of the Canadian
Security intelligence service the FBI
MI5 and their counterparts from
Australia and New Zealand meet in a
public forum the reason the Chinese
Communist party is the number one threat
to Innovation
period China has made economic Espionage
stealing others work and ideas a central
component of its National strategy we
need to S send a clear message to
adversaries that we will counter
malicious activity and have something
that they do not the power of
Partnerships the Spy Chiefs met in the
heart of Silicon Valley to deliver a
public warning to private sector
businesses that China is attempting to
infiltrate private sector firms working
on artificial intelligence and other
Next Generation digital Technologies we
see the the PRC uh the Chinese Communist
Party passing legislation to force any
person of Chinese or anywhere in the
world to support their intelligence
service we are at a historic moment
where emerging Technologies AI Quantum
Computing synthetic biology are leaping
forward in ways that have the potential
to change our world at a fundamental
level Canada's top spy David Vigo told
the group that China is not making any
secret of its objectives and that means
western governments are under pressure
to put more resources into
anti-espionage activi ities the PRC has
been you know and gping has been the
best advocate for all of us to do more
of what we do because they've been so
bold uh about what they're doing how
they have been stealing you know
intellectual property how they have
interfered in our Democratic processes
Vigo also cautioned that spy agencies
should avoid witch hunts that they
should not stigmatize all Chinese or all
Russians he said it is the Chinese
Communists and Vladimir Putin's corrupt
regime that represent the West's real
threats Donna okay David aen thanks the
close relationship between Russia and
China was on display in Beijing today
Vladimir Putin making a rare trip
outside his country Russian president is
attending Chinese president xiin Ping's
third belt and Road Forum it's an event
aimed at building Global infrastructure
and energy networks connecting Asia with
Africa and Europe the last time these
two leaders met she called Putin his
dear friend new data shows inflation in
Canada easing coming up will look at
whether Canadians are feeling
relief there is some good news from
statistics Canada today inflation dipped
to 3.8% in September down from 4% in
August though as Heather urick West
reports Canadians are still feeling the
squeeze when it comes to putting a roof
over their
heads inflation might be falling but
astd nickerson's living costs are are
still on the rise a rent hike in
September means the single mom is barely
making ends meet I've just kind of been
going to the food bank more and like
cutting back on you know different
things like taking my son out places and
stuff Aaron mcferson moved to Calgary
for a job but has now found herself
living in a homeless shelter for the
first time in her life I did have a room
for it lined up and I actually ended up
getting scammed out of money along with
fuel stats can says the cost of housing
is the main source of inflation right
now as interest rate hikes aimed at
cooling the cost of living lead to
mortgage rate and Rental hikes instead
higher interest rates u mean demand for
rental housing is higher and also on the
cost side um you know higher interest
rates mean means it's more expensive for
a potential landlord to buy a house buy
an apartment to rent out uh so we kind
of have it from both
directions there is good news however at
the grocery store food inflation is
falling though economists warn prices
could creep up again in time for the
holidays we see real seasonality in
Canada relative to food prices with food
prices generally being lower um in the
late summer and early fall and then
going up around the Christmas time the
Bank of Canada is set to make another
interest rate decision next week after
rapidly Rising its Benchmark by four and
3/4 percentage points since March of
2022 most analysts expect rates will
hold steady for people like astred
Nickerson this month's been pretty tight
I have dimes to go get coffee there's
just no room for any more cost of living
hikes Heather urix West Global News
Calgary the man accused of murdering
four members of a Muslim family and who
is facing terrorism charges is
testifying on his own behalf at his
trial Nathaniel veltman has pleaded not
guilty to four counts of first-degree
murder and one count of attempted murder
there is no question he ran down the
afel family in June of 2021 but as Mike
drle reports the jury will have to
decide whether he is criminally
responsible Nathaniel veltman didn't
know the afol family but they fit the
profile for what he was looking for so
he turned his truck around and drove
right at them were you thinking clearly
Mr veltman asked his lawyer he answered
my mind was a
mess before that deadly night in London
Ontario in June 2021 one feltman says he
thought of himself as an enlightened
individual who said he knew the truth
about Muslims others didn't know he
testified that he knew he was obsessed
saying if I act out on it then I'll be
free a stark contrast to what he told
police after his arrest so I decided all
right this is it I'm going to I'm going
to commit a terrorist attack I'm done
I'm not putting up with this anymore the
crown is seeking to prove the killings
were both planned and deliberate and in
a Canadian first were of white
nationalist terrorism feltman has
pleaded not guilty and his defense team
may try to convince the jury he is not
criminally responsible Felman told
police he had been planning the attack
for months and had written his own
Manifesto inspired by other Mass
murderers but veltman now says the
statements he made to police were made
under duress to justify his actions he
testified I was trying to say every
possible thing I could to police and
that the truth is that he felt this
massive shock and horror so was the now
22-year-old in his right mind it's a
very very difficult defense to prove it
is an extremely difficult defense to
prove and for good reasons right you can
imagine The Floodgate the the you know
everyone um would claim that um you know
they were suffering from some kind of
mental disorder if it's going to lead to
them not being found criminally liable
there's no question veltman committed
the acts what the jury will have to
ascertain is the key to this trial his
intent Mike trle Global
News still ahead the looming presence of
Hezbollah in the Middle East who are
they and what do they
[Music]
want the Lebanese based militant group
Hezbollah is calling for a day of
unprecedented anger against Israel after
the bombing of a hospital in Gaza and
along the Israel Lebanon border
Hezbollah says five more of its Fighters
have been killed Israel and Hezbollah
which is backed by Iran have been
exchanging fire there for the past week
and fears are mounting about where all
of this is headed Redmond Shannon
explains video released by militant
group Hezbollah appears to show Rockets
hitting Northern
Israel Israel is firing shells in the
opposite direction as it evacuates its
border region inal the head of Israel's
Armed Forces tells troops to retaliate
hard if Hezbollah attacks Israel killed
more fighters from the heavily armed
iran-backed group Tuesday the two sides
fought a month-long war in 2006 that
ended in a
ceasefire Iran's foreign minister said
Monday that unless the West can pull
Israel back from invading Gaza the
possibility of a new second front
against Israel is inev itable suggesting
even a preemptive
strike Western leaders including German
Chancellor Olaf Schultz have instead
asked Hezbollah to step back as Middle
Eastern leaders fear for what happens
next the whole region is at the brink of
falling into the abyss that this new
cycle of death and destruction is
pushing us towards nobody wants to fight
a twoof front War even a very well
supplied very well maintained Israeli
milit
Lebanon is a is almost a basket case and
I think if if Hezbollah risked what
would be a protracted war with Israel uh
the possibility of lebanon's collapse
would be increased hezbollah's call for
a day of unprecedented anger in the wake
of the Gaza Hospital blast will do
little to ease fears of an escalation
Redmond Channon Global News
London next the heavy burden of medical
staff in
Gaza
what's happening in Gaza and Israel can
seem overwhelming and we are aware the
images and the stories are difficult to
watch it is easier to turn away there
are always those who can't turn away
though whose job it is to help the
injured and in some cases they are
mourning while they do
it funeral prayers outside gaza's shifa
Hospital the job of Staff here is to
heal but in Gaza right now too often
they simply cannot
Dr Abdullah abuad could not save his
wife and children who died when their
house was hit Dr Hassan abua flew from
London to help at gaza's largest
hospital there is he says no lonelier
place than at the bed of a wounded child
who has no more family to look after
them people are exhausted uh the medical
staff are absolutely
exhausted 14 doctors have been killed 13
nurses my colleagues have had families
killed they've lost their homes
um and so the capacity of the system to
treat these wounded that keep coming in
is unending he sent this picture of an
empty operating room who will ever wash
away all this Blood he asks the time to
mourn is brief and then medical staff
carry on finding Comfort where they can
in the arms of
colleagues and that is global national
for this Tuesday I'm Donna freezen
funerals and burials are happening every
day in Israel and in Gaza as the
prospect of Peace in the Middle East
grows ever more distant thanks for
watching
[Music]
for